uh
okay hi everyone welcome to another
episode of
science and technology history
uh q a so let's see we had a bunch of
questions
saved up here um
let's see all right let's take this one
from mikhail
question was why did we as a
as humanity spends so much time not
building technology
when the greeks had invented so many
things before zero bc
that's an interesting question i'm not
sure i know all the answers but let's
talk a little bit about that
so first question is
what technology did exist in the ancient
world
and what drove further development of
technology
through time i think it's important to
understand that
technology development tends to be
driven by people's needs
and the there was
uh there had been different kinds of
drivers
for needs so for example wars are often
a big driver for technology needs
and in ancient times people were
inventing siege machines and so on
in more modern times people were
developing airplanes inventing radar
developing nuclear weapons all these
kinds of things as
something driven by uh the needs of war
and um that that's you know it's one of
the paradoxes of wars
is that for all their bad features they
tend to have the
the the good feature usually it's a good
feature of
advancing the development of technology
people
people kind of uh uh you know
do more and energize on those kinds of
things in those types of situations
i think that um uh in the ancient world
as i say quite a bit of technology was
developed for for things like siege
machines and so on you know how do you
how do you throw something you know how
do you make this giant um
catapult like thing that throws
something over the walls of a city
how do you
do things where um
do do things like that um
i think you know realistically it's not
a it's not a great thing
to to talk about but realistically one
of the reasons that
that certain kinds of technology were
not as much developed i think in the
ancient world
is that they were humans often slaves
who
just would do a lot of stuff and it's
like why make a machine
when you can have a person do it now of
course if we
reflect that to modern times you might
ask
in the development of technology why
aren't all the factories robotic you
know
can't we make robotic factories and
isn't that a better idea
well robots are hard to make you know
there are problems like how do you even
grasp an object you know if you're
if you're even doing packing for you
know shipping out a bunch of stuff
to for retail or something how do you
how do you pick up all these weird
shaped objects and
put them in boxes to ship ship around to
places
that turns out to be a really hard
problem and you know in
with modern machine vision machine
learning
robot control and so on it once
gradually getting closer to the problem
how do you pick up a weird shaped object
and be able to put it in a box but even
that isn't easy and a lot of what's done
in robotic factories these days is still
really quite primitive and really quite
based on
sort of very specific programming move
this robot arm to this position
this number of millimeters above this
thing
and do this it's not at all uh
you know use the eyes of the robot and
figure out what to do so
so you know if the things that are
coming in i don't know fruit picking or
something and
and it's each each piece of fruit has a
different shape that's a challenging
thing
it's when the thing is precise you can
build a system
that will precisely robotically do this
or that
but so so the question of why aren't
there more robotic production lines
in the world uh well the answer is
because they're expensive
and it's very non-trivial to build them
and it's still in the world today for
many kinds of things like you know
assembling an iphone or something
it's cheaper to use labor in some parts
of the world
than it is to uh set up that whole
robotic factory
have it all work and um have uh
and have things some um uh
be um uh you know have have um
uh have everything be based on robots i
mean for example tesla
um i know elon musk has lots of
personal frustration about about the
difficulty of actually debugging a robot
factory
um and uh uh you know i think it's
it's um i'm sure when henry ford was
first
developing production lines he too had
to personally go
and uh debug aspects of the production
line but any case that you know it's one
of the things that tesla for example
has done that's some that's quite bold
is to try and make uh much more robotic
production lines than than people have
done before
but for many purposes the drive you
might say
in modern times why don't we have more
robotic production lines
well the answer is because people are
still cheaper as a way
of of making lots of things than
the uh than the cost of production lines
i i'm i'm hesitating a little bit as i'm
saying this because
of course it's a complicated thing
because the people you have to pay
incrementally
the robot production line to some extent
you just make a big investment up front
and then it just runs itself
because it doesn't really run itself it
has to be maintained
it requires you know complex uh
work by usually a smaller number of
people but but with
more complex skills um to keep the
production line running
but so you know if we look back to
ancient greek times
people might have said well why are we
going to make automation to do this or
that thing why do we make
you know why would we make an automated
um
uh i don't know um great
harvesting machine when we can just have
humans pick the grapes
and i think that's part of the dynamic
of why more technology didn't develop
there
i think we see that in modern times with
uh
with interest in some parts of the world
like japan and in robotics
for for taking care of uh
the the older population and so on
because
it's like there there aren't even people
to pay
to do it so uh you know so you kind of
are driven into into some kind of
automation
but i think you know automation happens
only often happens only when it needs to
happen i'll give you another example
in software engineering one of the
things that
has been a long time objective of mine
is to sort of automate as much as you
can
about the production of software and
about building computations
that's kind of one of the big stories of
wolfram language
is make things as automatic as possible
now you might say
why isn't that something everybody wants
to do in software engineering make
things as automatic as possible
well the answer is because particularly
with the sort of successes of the tech
industry
it's often it's perfectly easy just to
pay humans to do it doesn't matter
you can pay humans to write individual
lines of javascript code
why bother to automate it you can just
pay the humans to do it
so it's another case where the drive for
automation
is is not as great as you might think it
would be i mean in our own case
my own calculation is to have a company
that's comparatively small
and where we have automated as much as
we can so that with a comparatively
small number of people
we can achieve a lot i'll give you
another example of a drive for
automation and how that happens
as a company uh its name is actually
emerald cloud lab and uh it started off
as a as a company that was
was doing uh sort of drug development
um using trying to develop kind of
algorithmic drugs
with a very interesting kind of
scientific direction
that had some relations to a bunch of
science that i've done about simple
programs and so on
but it was a very kind of a bold
direction of building a new platform for
drug development
um that was sort of making kind of
algorithmic drugs
well it was a small company and as uh
as a result it had sort of the the
difficulty of how we're going to run all
these experiments how are we going to
set them all up
we don't have the money to pay all these
people to do it
so what they did is they built an
automated lab
and they took many years building this
automated lab and eventually
turns out that automated lab is a super
valuable thing in its own right and so
actually they split up a separate
company
that's the emerald cloud lab thing that
it's just dealing with this
much higher level of automation in a
biology and chemistry lab and that's
something that's actually
rolling out in the next little while um
but that's something where again
if you're a pharma company and you're
doing all these experiments and things
it's like you might as well just pay the
humans to to put things in test tubes
and
do all those kinds of things because
that's actually that's not where you're
spending most of your money
it's some uh that's a that's a
reasonable economic thing to
do but because these guys at emerald
uh had this sort of economic constraint
that
they just couldn't pay for the
the the all the humans necessarily did
all these experiments they had to
automate it
and so that drove the creation of
technology in that particular small
example
so so i think one of the things that
sort of holds back
the development of technology is you
don't need to do it because you can just
have humans do things rather than
automate those things
again sometimes uh for example in in
in cases of i don't know something like
uh you know war is one of the drivers
uh sometimes medicine is another driver
uh
where you have a situation where
where um uh you just can't do something
without having more technology then you
develop the technology now of course
there are other
there are other funky cases like in the
financial area
there's all kinds of technology that at
least i don't know whether it's
first developed there but it certainly
uh has developed
development there where for example
you're saying well i want to get some
advantage by knowing
this data a little bit faster than these
other guys
um and uh you know it's i think it may
be an apocryphal story but
um that uh you know galileo first
licensed his telescope to the merchants
of venice so that they could run up that
tower in the middle of venice
and look out at the horizon and see
whose ships were coming in and
whose weren't and go trade in the in the
market um based on that information
faster than the other guys could so that
was sort of
a telescope developed for for the sake
of a financial advantage
and and sometimes again there are these
these strange constraints that drive
technology development another one
that's a slightly funky story is about
semiconductor development the
development of microprocessors and so on
uh one of the drivers for that
was uh uh companies like slumberge
oil instrumentation company that wanted
to put these very sophisticated tools
in oil wells and uh uh wanted to have
them
and and you'd end up with something
which had all this discrete components
discrete electronic components
and the tool will be 200 feet long and
by the time you've got a 200-foot thing
going down a big
oil well and maybe the the oil well
uh the the the sort of the the the
drilling hole
maybe got uh for for different reasons
would turn
and then this 200 foot long thing would
just break as you put it down
this uh this oil well so it's like okay
then it's worth investing in
semiconductors
because they're going to reduce the size
of uh the micro
of the of the computational elements
that we have to put down these uh these
oil wells
let's let's invest in semiconductors so
we can minimize
so we can sort of miniaturize this um uh
this this device
and you know again there are there are
there are all these different places
where sort of technology development is
driven by different kinds of things you
know
you have ships they're going and trading
over long distances and things like this
they might get lost how can you prevent
them getting lost well you have to start
developing navigation technology and
things like this to to to provide that
so i
i think an important piece of the story
of technology
is when is it needed what's driving the
development
and it's some necessity that's driving
the development and if there's another
solution
people will often not make that
invention um
they'll they'll find a way to just sort
of patch around things rather than
having to make the invention
so i think in uh in the time
i mean i suppose in the in the period of
time
from um i would say that the the roman
empire was impressive
for developing lots of engineering
solutions whether they're aqueducts or
uh other kinds of um um
you know i think they were particularly
big on things like plumbing and roads
and things
like this and and then as society
changed after the fall of the roman
empire
it's not clear whether uh
whether those things didn't get
developed more just because the goals of
society had changed somewhat
or what um and so i think um
i mean this question of of sort of why
does technology get developed at certain
times and not others
is is partly driven by these you know
what does society consider is important
i mean
today uh the um
you know i guess in this pandemic for
example there's all sorts of technology
that has been being driven to be
developed
whether it's mrna vaccines or whether
it's uh
various kinds of tightening up of
various kinds of
remote working technology and so on
that's sort of driven by that necessity
now another question is when you're
building
sort of technology there's a certain
stack of capabilities that you need to
reach a certain level of technology like
let's say you're trying to build
microprocessors what do you need to
build a microprocessor
you need a whole huge tower of
technology to build microprocessors
which is why when people say let's set
up a microprocessor factory in country x
well it might not be so easy because you
know you'll need um
uh all kinds of services there to
support that microbrexit factory even
given that you know how to build the
microprocessor factory
and getting to the point where you have
you know you can make something that's
perfectly clean
you can deal with having this sort of
very microscopic control of things
you can understand enough about the
physics of semiconductors
there are all these different kinds of
things that you need to sort of have
this tower of
to be able to create uh that particular
technology
so i think uh you know when you look at
kind of the um uh the history of
different
kinds of technology um there's this
effect of you have to have a stack of
things in order to get to a certain
point
uh you have to have a necessity to do
things i mean
like for example another another good
example of lack of necessity
is a lot of deep space probe technology
and so on and
space exploration technology it's like
there was a big push
for reasons of national pride and other
kinds of things in the 1960s
to do uh you know space exploration and
so on
and that necessity decayed after that
time
and then not a lot's been done until
quite recently in those areas
and uh you know that's something where
where again
it's like if it wasn't needed it didn't
get done so to speak if there wasn't a
push to get it done
it wasn't going to get done um
i think sometimes people there are
things that
like this is a really good idea but
people
don't see its significance at a certain
time
um what's a good example of that well
here's an example
a lot of uh and sometimes it's the
complicated mess of how technology
develops i mean
okay so sometimes there's an idea for a
piece of technology but it just doesn't
work well enough to be used for some
new purpose like a good example is eye
glasses
they were developed um oh i don't know
when but they
uh they they long predated the telescope
and for example people like kepler
didn't have telescopes
but i think he did actually wear glasses
at some point and how could that work
and why would he not have used that
to make a telescope well the answer is
because i think
because the lenses weren't really quite
good enough to
to they were good enough to help in in
doing uh you know
uh close-up work and reading things and
so on if you
if you have presbyopia or whatever but
um they weren't good enough
to um uh to make something sort of where
you had multiple lenses together making
something like a telescope
so it was a case where sort of to get to
the point where you could make a
telescope
you had to uh sort of you have to have
developed
lenses to be really really
uh sort of high quality enough to make a
telescope another good example
drones uh you know why weren't
uh multi-rotor uh sort of vertical
takeoff
aeroplane like things developed a long
time ago well there were sort of things
a bit like that
but the control systems technology
wasn't good enough there weren't
microprocessors
the uh the battery technology wasn't
good enough you had to have
you know and you you'd have to use an
internal combustion engine and things
back in the day
um and you might have to have a person
trying to pull all these controls and
that wasn't easy to do
so it was one of these things where yes
in principle it was doable and there are
funky movies of people you know having
quadrotor
type devices um from back in the
certainly 1950s i would say maybe even
earlier than that
um but it didn't things didn't quite
work well enough and then suddenly
about uh what was it a little less than
10 years ago now
sort of all the technology pieces came
together and it became practical to do
that
so that's another kind of thing is when
do things get good enough that you can
actually do this or that thing
i mean i remember uh flat screen
televisions you know i had seen a flat
screen television back in the mid 1980s
but um they weren't sort of the it
wasn't possible to get production yields
that were good enough
to put them out as consumer products
until uh
well into the um 1990s even maybe early
2000s
so uh that there are these kinds of
other
dynamics of what limits the the speed of
of um of of technology adoption
i was trying to think of an example of a
case where
people really had the idea of something
but nobody cared so to speak it was it
was a device
that just didn't have um uh didn't have
a use case
um until something changed in society
that caused it to to need to be used um
and uh not thinking of a great example
of that but i but i think there are
are examples of that well anyway long
answer to a question about some
um uh
um about sort of what what has driven
or held back the development of
technology and and why
aren't we uh why were there long periods
of time when not a lot of technology was
being developed
and and i think part of the answer is is
because people just didn't have enough
need for it
and there wasn't enough of a push to to
make those things happen i mean
it's very funny if you look at the
history of technology these there's sort
of bursts of activity in
areas like in in england in a certain
period in
in what the the well there was a good
run in england of technology development
um from uh what the 16 1700s 1800s was a
really good run
of technology development there you know
why did it happen there
and not in other places um why
i i think these are these sort of
complicated issues
it's part of the partly related to these
stories about you know
why do so many movies get made in
hollywood and not in somewhere else why
do so many
uh technology companies accumulate in
silicon valley
um you know there tend to be these these
situations that happen
where there is a sort of culture of
doing things in a particular
place and there's a lot of
infrastructure available in that place
to do those things
and so a lot gets done there and it's
the same in both space and time
there's you know people get used to the
idea that
oh you can make inventions and you can
get patents and that really works
or you can make inventions and uh
and people will think your you know your
cool
type thing and that really works in a
certain society at a certain time
and so then more and more of that
happens in that place at that time
and uh in other places it's it's often
hard to get started and
and just doesn't happen so you know
those are sort of accidents of history
but they're
they're in a sense they are their things
and when you look back at them you can
say oh well
this happened because there were these
investors who started investing in these
kinds of things and they were this and
they were that
but quite often there would have been a
bunch of other places where those things
could have happened
they just didn't happen and the kind of
self-fulfilling uh
mechanism didn't get started so to speak
the positive feedback loop didn't get
started in
in that place at that time and uh it's
always an interesting question how you
can start those things um and uh what
you know if you're interested in
developing some particular country or
region or whatever
um how do you get those kinds of things
started to to make uh technology
development happen there
um anyway okay
let's see
all sorts of things here um
there's a question here do i think the
most important technical advances
are due to individuals or groups
you know any serious technology
development
is going to end up needing a group of
people but
the leadership of that effort will
typically be one person
it's and the style of leadership will
determine
whether it's like that person is the
main person doing this
or whether the the style of leadership
will be more
like uh behind the scenes so to speak
where it just looks like the team is
doing it
but i think it's fair to say that that
any
any technical project will need
leadership it doesn't just sort of
naturally happen at least it doesn't
naturally happen
well um i think that um uh but the
leadership may be a little bit behind
the scenes so it's less visible
to uh to the public or to the history
book so to speak
um but yeah i think it's it's um and
when it comes to sort of how large a
team does it take
to really do some serious piece of
technology development
you know often there are many layers to
that there's kind of the
the core idea making and then there's
the actual implementation and deployment
and maybe there's the actual uh you know
running the electric cables all around
the world type thing
which is a uh which requires a lot more
people
but it's not at the point where there
have to be sort of the core ideas there
may be specific ideas to
you know how do we run this electrical
cable through this particular thing
those are engineering problems that have
to be solved but
and that might require lots of lots of
quite talented people to be able to
solve those problems
but it's a little different than the
original core more basic problem of
you know how do we make an electric
generator or something like this
um and i think the uh the the world of
kind of the
the lone inventor that's a pretty rare
case
and and pretty specific to situations in
which
uh for one reason or another the cost of
of taking the next
step is is is lower i mean in software
for example that that does happen
that there can be sort of the lone
inventor who writes
a big chunk of software that turns out
to be useful um
and because in a sense there are places
where sort of the
the cost of development the cost of
producing a
of a thing that could actually be
deployed in the real world
has become low enough that it's possible
for an individual person to do it
but i think that's a pretty rare case
let's see uh
question here
okay there's a question here from cut
off about what are the greatest
true things that stephen hawking
discovered
um well i think uh
excuse me
i think uh i
i i knew stephen hawking though not
particularly well
um i would say that the the most
important discovery was this phenomenon
called hawking radiation
um and that was uh discovered in what
1973 maybe
there had been um
a bunch of kind of related work done
but the key question was when you have a
okay black holes this phenomenon
that was sort of an inevitable
consequence of einstein's general theory
of relativity from 1915
but their significance really wasn't
understood until kind of the 1960s or so
it was very confusing whether they were
just sort of mathematical artifacts
whether they were real things that could
happen from collapsing stars
those kinds of things that sort of kind
of clarified by about the 1960s
and so then one of the questions was
okay so you have this black hole
it's this gravitational phenomenon where
you have this event horizon
where things can go into the event
horizon but nothing can come out of the
event horizon sort of the
the uh the escape velocity is is of the
black hole is
is more than the speed of light nothing
can escape so to speak
that that story became reasonably clear
by the by the 1960s
and um then the question was well
another thing that was sort of in the
air was quantum field theory
quantum field theory had been developed
originally
in uh the well it was originally started
a bit about in the 1920s
right around the time when when ordinary
quantum mechanics and things like
schrodinger's equation and diracs
equation and so on
were developed people wondered we've got
this quantum theory
for uh for things like an electron a
single electron
but what about a field like an
electromagnetic field
and what about an electron that can emit
photons
what about something where you have a
system where the number of particles
doesn't remain
fixed you're not just talking about a
single electron that's moving around
and asking what's the chance to find it
in different places in a box or
something like this
or different places in a hydrogen atom
or something but you're asking the
question
if the number of particles can change if
the electron can emit photons for
example
how does that work at the level of
quantum mechanics and for that
this idea of quantum field theory was
invented and by the by the late 1920s
the basic uh notions of quantum field
theory had been laid down
the basic idea that what you would think
about was
a quantum field would be something where
it
could have an arbitrary number of
particles there would be sort of a
component of a quantum field that was
the one particle component
then the two particle component three
particle component and so on these are
things called fox spaces
uh where the um uh where it's kind of a
notion of
you have all these different numbers of
particles and they
they all sort of are together
representing this quantum field
so early on it was pretty hard to
compute much with quantum field there
was very mathematically complicated
by the 1940s quantum electrodynamics the
quantum
field theory of electrons and photons
was decently well developed and people
started being able to do real
computations the big
so breakthrough there was the idea of
normalization um
which was a way of getting rid of uh
sort of infinities that would naturally
crop up in the computations done in that
theory
but by the by the 1950s or so
uh quantum electrodynamics was kind of a
machine
for computing things to do with
electrons and photons and
and lots of interesting calculations
were done and people were like wow this
is really cool
it agrees very perfectly with experiment
things are really working
there was then an attempt to extend
quantum field theory
from the theory of electrons and photons
to theories of other kinds of particles
like atomic nuclei and the things that
hold atomic nuclei together and so on
that wasn't very successful and
through the 1960s basically
there was a well quantum field theory is
kind of not
it works for quantum electrodynamics but
it's not really going to be extendable
and uh really we have to have other
theories like for things the precursors
of string theory and so on
um other theories to explain other kinds
of particle phenomena so
but still quantum field theory was was
out and about and
you know quantum electrodynamics worked
well and there was sort of
increasing belief that maybe nuclear
beta decay might be described by
something
that corresponds to a quantum field
theory and similarly other kinds of
particle things
but so there was sort of a an almost
mathematical question of if we now
combine
this idea of quantum field theory with
the idea of general relativity and black
holes
what will happen and and sort of the
most
significant thing that stephen hawking
did was to try and do
a first step in that in that uh in that
combination
and he worked out this idea of hawking
radiation
and i have to say that i for example
was was for a long time very unconvinced
that this would actually be a real thing
because what it required doing was
taking the mathematical apparatus on
field theory
and grafting it on to the mathematical
apparatus of general relativity
and it wasn't clear that you could put
those two things together it wasn't
clear that the approximations being made
on the two sides were compatible with
each other
but so that was so what hawking
did was to say yes you can put the
mathematics together in this way
and you have a physical prediction that
black holes should produce radiation
and and for a while it was thought that
one might observe these exploding black
holes because
as the black hole emits radiation the
smaller the black hole gets the more
intensely emits radiation and so when
the black hole gets very very small it's
sort of a runaway process
and there's this kind of burst as the
black hole explodes
well we've never actually observed
directly hawking radiation
in a black hole um it's it's uh
too too small to observe um in typical
black holes
if there happened to be black holes
about the mass of mount everest that
were created in the early universe
then we might see them kind of popping
off and exploding right around now but
that doesn't seem to be happening
there are sort of analogs of black holes
in other kinds of situations where the
mathematics is more or less the same
but one's not dealing with gravity once
dealing with
things in in condensed matter systems
and so on where sort of black hole
hooking radiation like phenomena have
been observed
but at this point the mathematical
structure the approximations that
stephen hawking made and so on
to get hawking radiation yeah they're
they're pretty
validated because there's just this huge
structure that now exists
around um kind of the the merger of
quantum field theory and general
relativity
that makes it seem like everything now
sort of uh
that there's there's enough consistency
in what's going on that it kind of
probably pretty much works the way that
stephen hawking said it would work
i have to say that in our uh theory of
physics we can start seeing this stuff
much more explicitly
we've we've almost got to the point of
being able to simulate
uh the event horizon of black hole and
seahawking radiation but we're not quite
there yet
there's actually another bizarre
phenomenon that i'm calling black hole
wind
which is essentially a it's a it's a
different version of something like
caulking radiation
that uh relates to gravitational
radiation from black holes or what might
look like gravitational radiation from
black holes
that i sort of started investigating
last year but um but that's that's
getting us
off topic here um i think that that
the the um so that's uh as i see it
that's the sort of the
the core thing and the thing that's
non-trivial is you take these two
different theories
you put them together you make a
prediction it's just not clear that
that's going to possibly work and so
that's the
that's kind of the the the kudos really
goes
to um to stephen hawking for having sort
of
had the the boldness to say this really
is going to fit together this way
and that's how it's going to work
physically and not just oh here's one
mathematical approximation
here's another one i don't really know
what's going to happen when you put
those two things together
well let's see um
that's there's a question here about um
how is research changing in universities
is safe to assume
that most research and innovation will
come from private industry
oh this is an interesting question you
know one question is what is the role
what what are universities supposed to
be for and
you know when they were founded in the
1200s the
the primary mission i think was
education
and was taking knowledge that had
existed and passing it down to
successive generations
and that's a that's a pretty good
mission
but at some point that mission got
combined with the mission of create new
knowledge
it's not clear that those missions have
to be part of the same thing i mean we
don't expect
your typical k-12 teacher to be creating
new knowledge
we expect that they'll be passing
knowledge to successive generations
and but we expect that at least some
professors at some universities
are creating new knowledge as part of
sort of
the professoring business so to speak
that merger
of sort of research with education is a
is a it's well it's it's it's happened
to some extent for quite a while but in
some ways it's a it's a new phenomenon
and it doesn't happen the same way in
all countries
i mean in some countries the industrial
research labs or the government labs
are the primary places where research is
expected to be done
universities are much more the place
where education is expected to be done
and um so you know there's a question
then
of when one is seeing innovation happen
how does it where should it happen you
know one of the challenges with
innovation it's a sort of bizarre
self-defeating phenomenon is
when you might say you know there's some
field the bigger the field is the more
innovation is going to happen
well it often doesn't work that way
because
the greatest innovation the sort of
highest rate of change
tends to be in these places that are
kind of at the boundaries of the margins
for example at the margins between two
different fields or in some place where
some new field is being created
and those places sort of by definition
aren't the places where things are big
yet
by the time things are big it's often a
sign that the
most fertile period of innovation is
over for that particular field
and when things get big it often becomes
more difficult to have additional
innovation because people are saying
there's this whole institutional
structure you know you've got to fit in
in this way and this way in this way
if you're doing something new and
different hey that doesn't fit into the
institutional structure
we can't get that funded you can't have
a job doing that and
in this department and so on and so the
bigness actually slows things down in
many cases
so that's that's been one of one of the
issues and i think sometimes
in the past maybe uh i don't know
in universities um maybe
what was it now by by the now by now 70
years ago 80 years ago more than that
a hundred years ago even there was a lot
of uh sort of
a professor as an island so to speak and
just
you know there was a professor and they
were just doing what they did and they
would give lectures and hopefully the
students would come to those lectures
in some countries there was a direct
feedback loop to people getting paid
based on students coming to their
lectures
in other places that wasn't really how
it worked but it was kind of like
individual professor types and they
often weren't called professors
some countries the more germanic
countries they were tended to be called
professors
in in england for example the the title
professor
really meant the head of a department
who was administratively running things
rather than the person who was
necessarily doing the fanciest
work so to speak um the uh but in any
case in
in many cases you know if you look back
at the time of i don't know
uh alan turing or at the time of um
even isaac newton you know much much
earlier or
many of these kinds of people these were
sort of individual people
just who were who were paid for many
cases by universities
but were just doing their own thing so
to speak as opposed to people embedded
within
large systems where there's some whole
flow of funding and this
some whole department that's doing this
or that thing and and so on i mean there
was a there was a
and you know from a personal point of
view
one of the things that was common i
don't know about all countries but in
england it was a pretty common thing
that people would get you know college
fellowships at a young age
and then fundamentally they were set for
life to just go
do figure stuff out and do what they
wanted to do
there are other countries like i think
france has a system with cnrs uh which
sort of uh
appoints people comparatively early in
life to some sort of lifelong system of
of being funded to do research
um and i think that from a
from a societal point of view that those
systems can be pretty good
because you're saying to people okay you
can do whatever you want
which means you can do innovative things
you don't have to necessarily
toe this line or that line because
you're kind of set
from an individual point of view it's
it's not necessarily such a good deal
because
you set somebody up at a young age and
you say okay you're just set to go
thinking for the rest of your life that
can be a very
difficult uh kind of situation to be in
sounds good at the beginning but it's
like okay you know
what do you really have to do well i
don't really have to do anything
well you know 10 years later it's like
well i don't really feel like doing
anything
i'm not going to do anything for the
next 10 years and and pretty soon things
sort of spiral
down and not much happens but so
for society it might actually be a good
bet because let's say one in three of
those people
does something really innovative two out
of three might not
have particularly good outcomes um and
that's bad for those individual people
but from society's point of view having
that one out of three
that really does something spectacular
can be a big win
now you know in other countries and
other times it's like well it's not fair
to pick this person
because they seem promising and give
them this fantastic deal
sort of things should be made more equal
and fair
well if you do that and you say well
everybody's got to go through this whole
process of you know this 10-year 15-year
process
of of towing the line so they get tenure
at their university or whatever
by the time you've done that people are
you know
uh you know they've been doing that so
many years
that they've probably lost whatever
energy they had at the beginning
to go off and do innovative things
they'll just say you know what i'm just
going to keep towing this line i'm not
going to do anything terribly innovative
so there are there are sort of that's a
dynamic that tends to happen
now the question is where and when do
people really get to do new and
different things
and it's complicated because you need
a certain amount of freedom to do new
and
innovative things but also there tends
to be
a certain driver of necessity that helps
in doing new and innovative things i'm
not sure it's
it's when it comes to basic research i'm
not sure that that's always
quite as necessary as it is in
technology but it's still
if somebody just says okay you're
thinking for the next 25 years
um it's like okay what am i supposed to
think about but if somebody
uh if you're for whatever reason you're
like i've got to solve the problem
of some uh sort of big problem in
mathematics or something
it's like that's a driver that gives you
a direction
and then if you have the freedom to
actually be able to think about it for
10 years or something
then that can be a big win but i think
it's
it's if you look at the different
entities where it's possible for
innovation to occur
they're different kinds of places i mean
they're universities
that have a very definite rhythm at this
point they have bundled together
uh their educational mission in many
cases with a research mission
often with funding from governments and
things like that
uh where there's very definite programs
that are trying to achieve this or that
thing
um that um uh that go in different
directions and which limit
the domain the amount of innovation that
can happen because it's like well you
can innovate as much as you want so long
as it applies to
this very specific thing and that
doesn't really
get you kind of free unfettered
innovation so to speak
so you know that's what tended to happen
at the universities and it's a very rare
case
where somebody says i'm just a professor
i've got tenure
i can do whatever i want i'm just going
to do this weird stuff
you know a friend of mine this is now
when was this was in the even in the uh
1970s at um distinguished university
which i won't name
the um this person was a physicist
and he decided he was really interested
in biology
and so he had tenure and was a fine you
know
successful tenured physics professor he
said well
actually i want to go work on biology
and the university said
well then your tenure doesn't apply
anymore you know if you go and set up a
lab in the biology department you start
working on biology
well then you know tenure doesn't count
anymore you can't go do that
now later on people started saying we
want to do interdisciplinary research we
want to have these connections between
this and that
you know often the reason why that's
ending up being said is because people
know
that the the rapid rates of innovation
come in these margins between different
fields and and so interdisciplinary
sounds good
but you don't need interdisciplinary
unless you have disciplinary so to speak
unless you have
you know these big structures of these
you know big departments that just do
this specific thing
and i think that um uh so you know the
the it's a rare case where you have sort
of the
the individual loose professor at the
university who's just working on
whatever
whatever uh sort of funky thing they
want to work on and potentially doing
something very
new and different the vast majority of
the situation
so are ones where there's a definite
flow constrained by
departments and funding and this and
that and the other and even the
communities in which people find
themselves
like you know you can't work on this if
you're in the such and such
uh physics community you know you'll be
if you suddenly start working on
i don't know what um you know that
that'll be
too shocking and uh you'll be sort of
ostracized from that community
so i think there's there's sort of that
dynamic operating in universities
when it comes to uh things like
well in different countries there are
different setups but government labs
industrial labs and so on there are
existing sort of
set up labs which can sometimes be quite
well managed and sometimes can
can induce innovation in particularly
in certain general directions for which
there is a way to sort of take that
innovation and do something with it
and then there's another case which is
start-up companies and entrepreneurial
kinds of kinds of things
i mean the an important feature of
startup companies is they usually fail
and that fact right there is interesting
and is a good thing for innovation in a
sense
because it's telling you that if if
there wasn't a lot of failure
it will be telling you there weren't a
lot of risks and there wasn't a lot of
let's just try doing this it might not
work so
insofar as there's sort of an ecosystem
for startups that
can fail that's probably a good thing
but of course
like everything the more startups there
are the more being an entrepreneur
becomes a
thing people do the more
institutionalized it gets
and the more constrained the system gets
so for example you might say
well let's you know we've got this great
idea about how to make a fusion reactor
or something
let's just go get venture capital for
that and make a startup company
well might might be a lot harder than
you think because
venture capital you might say they're
just going to take all these risks
no they're not you know they have
upstream investors
who've put money into this venture fund
to take certain very specific kinds of
risks
and in a sense it is you know a
complicated dance to de-risk
the the process of of giving out venture
capital by saying
we're going to do it in this particular
way where we understand roughly what the
rhythm
of that kind of company is going to be
we understand this or that thing i mean
i know i get asked quite a bit um by
friends of mine who are in venture
capital and so on
when there's mostly when there's a a
kind of a really new different
innovation type thing
they just say to startup companies ah no
thank you
we don't invest in that we invest in
specific kinds of software and this that
and the other but
but sometimes i'll get asked by friends
of mine about sort of these wilder
invention kinds of things you know is
this something that could possibly work
and uh most of the time even even when i
say yeah i think it could possibly work
it'll be like yeah we're not going to
invest in this it's too far away from
our
sort of core investment ideas so i think
you know innovation is it's it's tough
to have
a almost it's a it's a it's a sort of
self-defeating thing if you say let's
make a system
for causing innovation to happen that's
almost self-defeating because by the
time it gets big
it's going to have certain constraints
and it's not going to
not going to allow innovation to occur i
mean i know
for example i maybe i've told this the
story in this
this venue before but but um a a good
example
of sort of the the systematization of
innovation
uh in the soviet union for example there
was an attempt
to systematize innovation it was a thing
what was it called tric i think
uh probably stands for something in
russian it was a a system for innovating
that basically said you know you do
things like you take patents from one
area
that you can see in western patents or
something you take ones from another
area
and then you have the sort of way of of
of combining these two areas
and finding something in the middle that
will be an innovation
sort of an interesting idea but in a
sense
it it feels very self-defeating to say
we're going to make a system for
innovation
because in a sense anytime you have a
system you're kind of constraining
things and you're not allowing
this kind of free innovation uh
possibility
so you know in terms of the future
you know where will there be innovation
you know i think it
it it depends with respect to university
versus companies
it's a complicated dance and my guess is
it will it will
flit around to different places i think
at universities
one of the questions is what is the
mechanism for
creating a new direction at a university
and it's really hard
and and you know a lot of what we see is
uh things where you know the departments
were created
when funding started coming in after
world war ii
and they've kind of been the same
departments ever since that's a pretty
common thing
there were particular areas that got
created like molecular biology
was one area that just sort of sprung up
and departments were created there were
other areas like linguistics was an area
where departments were created that
didn't work out so well most of those
have been closed
there were there were um uh another
kind of area is computer science where
there weren't departments and even in
the 1980s
there were still many major universities
didn't have computer science departments
then those things were created i think
they're a little bit of a mess
in terms of what their mission is at
this point you know is it sort of a
trade school to teach people programming
is it a theoretical place where people
study sort of theory of computation is
it a place where
people study specific applications like
machine learning and so on
is it a place where people try and build
sort of academic versions of
of systems that might be relevant in the
real world those are
those are all slightly different subtly
different missions
that sometimes get bundled together and
sometimes people get very confused
about what the mission really is um and
uh
uh and whether uh you know it and
whether you can do i mean there's
you know to what extent can you do sort
of leading-edge
computer science-y type stuff in
universities well you can do some
um you can also do that kind of thing in
companies pretty well
and there's places where you really just
can't get that done in the university
because it requires too much kind of leg
work of too much
actual sort of real work of software
engineering
that you know a a a rotating door of
students doing it is just not going to
do it
you have to have systematic professional
people doing it
or you're just not going to be able to
build a workable system um
but uh so different dynamics for
different um
different kinds of things and you know
there are other places where
universities can be involved but
ultimately it's too big and too
expensive
to to be something that's going to
happen just to the university
let's see well i think we're we're
getting slightly short on time here but
let me um
look at a few more of these um
that's here's a question from david
brown about do i know various people at
renaissance technologies the answer that
is yes
um
let's see
oh boy there's a question from dl
do you think computer science is an
actual science
i mean theory of computation seems like
a science to me um
but there's a lot that seems like it's
engineering yeah
you know is it a science what does it
mean to be a science
i think to be a science there's
an operational definition would be
there's a core set of principles
that aren't just
that there are things that can be
studied abstractly
rather than just being used in practice
i mean i just made that definition up so
i'm not sure it's the most perfect
definition
but let's take that as a working
definition and explore computer science
in that um
in that context i mean it's it's often
said in a kind of wagy type way
that anything that has the word science
in its name
isn't really a science you know economic
science or
or well life science i don't know that's
pretty pretty sciencey
um but um in any case with computer
science
the question is what are the core ideas
and are there a core set of abstract
ideas
or is it all engineering details truth
is
there's a lot of engineering details and
a lot of what ends up getting taught in
computer science is engineering
details a lot of computer science
courses
are basically engineering details one
question
is to what extent are you teaching sort
of
eternal truths of computing and to what
extent are you teaching things which
work
this way because that's the way this
particular programming language was
designed at this particular time
and so on i think the what's happened in
computer science
is okay so so back when computer science
was young
there was theory of computation you know
turing machines
finite automata uh compilers things like
this
and that's what people used to teach in
computer science departments
and maybe the computer science
departments were plugged into electrical
engineering departments
and they taught things about actual
computer systems and so on there
as well but um uh that was that was kind
of the
the thing through the 1950s 1960s
1970s uh into the 1980s
and i remember that when we were first
hiring people
at our company in the in the late 1980s
we really didn't hire many people who
came from computer science departments
because they didn't really know things
that were really relevant to us
they knew stuff about theory of
computation it wasn't very applicable
it was kind of i thought it was very
interesting stuff i worked on that stuff
myself
but it wasn't something that we as a
company that was basically
making kind of sophisticated but
ultimately software tools
really needed and then there came this
moment
when computer science departments well a
lot of the actual
programming stuff have been taught in
things like
business schools and uh you know
mis systems what would they call them is
information systems and so on which
wasn't computer science
it was these other departments of
universities that were much closely more
closely aligned
with areas like accounting business and
so on
they would teach programming there and
they would teach sort of business
programming and so on there
um and then there came this moment i i
suppose in the 1990s
when there was sort of a big demand for
programmers programmers everybody need
needed programmers and people going to
colleges were saying
and i think i'm going to get a great job
if i study computing or computer science
and what was the what was the department
going to be called at a university well
it ended up being called computer
science
even though a lot of what was being
taught was basically how to program
and um and and not really things that
were very theoretical or abstract
now i think you know if you ask is there
theoretical abstract stuff
in i think there are there are three
areas so
there's computational x
there's the underlying theory of
computational things
and there's the practice of programming
and those are three different things
you know i think that one of the things
that
is very notable is the great paradigm of
the 21st century is the computational
paradigm
thinking about things in computational
terms thinking about
every possible field in computational
terms from you know
archaeology to zoology whatever in
computational terms how do you think
about
those animal migrations in computational
terms
how do you think about that
archaeological site in computational
terms
well how is quotes computer science as
taught in computer science departments
relevant to those things
most of it isn't terribly you know
writing knowing how to write
some uh i don't know some innards of
some database so knowing how to
uh set up some user interface or
something it's just not terribly
relevant
what's relevant in those places is sort
of the conceptual
uh foundations of computation and how
they can be applied to those fields and
indeed i've spent
a large chunk of my life building our
sort of computational language
to get people to the point where they
can apply computational ideas
across a lot of fields without being
down in the trenches
of computer science as it is often
sort of uh uh pervade in in sort of
uh in terms of programming so one thing
is kind of the ideas of computation how
do you think about things in
computational terms
how do you how do you conceptualize
things computationally
how do you take computational notions
and apply them to different kinds of
fields that's sort of bucket number one
not well handled in most universities at
this point uh
another bucket is purely learn to be a
programmer
it's kind of like learn to write english
you know it's a it's a skill
you know it happens with english uh you
know we have a good deal if we're
english speakers better than let's say
chinese or something where you have to
go much further in schooling
to get to the point where you can write
it fluently
um but in any case it's a it's a you
know it's a skill
writing english chinese whatever and um
uh and writing programs low-level
programs a bit like that
um and people one of the things that
gets very confusing
is there's a point in schooling where
you're not just
learning to write you end up just using
writing to write about lots of different
kinds of things
and i know even in the scribal schools
in ancient babylon
where they were sort of so first place
where they were teaching people to write
they would spend a few years teaching
people to write and they will break it
into these sort of five or six different
areas
where and then there are different
things you can write about you know you
can do accounting you can do this you
can do that
and so on so it's like writing x just
like we need
computational x right now and there's a
bit of a confusion in computer science
that maybe you know what do you do so
you learn a certain amount of
programming and then what do you program
about
and in computer science departments
there are these sort of funny things
that have been grafted on like
machine learning cryptography robotics
some of these kinds of areas which have
been sort of plugged in
as things you can program about now
those actually are very poor fits
because something like machine learning
or robotics for that matter these
require quite a bit of mathematics and
calculus and things like that
and people had even taken calculus out
of the typical computer science
curriculum
before machine learning came along
because it didn't seem relevant to
learning to program
that's kind of a sign it's it's a
different type of thing
so and then then there's the third area
which is
what what are the what is the abstract
theory of computational things
and there's a certain amount that's been
done in computation theory
and in things like the development of
computational complexity theory and so
on
i would argue that a lot of kinds of
things i've been very interested in
of exploring the computational universe
of simple programs and my whole
new kind of science direction i think
that really is
the pure end of computation and i think
that
what got done in the sort of development
from touring machines and so on
that segued into the more engineering
side of computation
let's use a turing machine for this
particular thing
rather than let's study turing machines
for their own sake there's still a
pure computation area of let's study
turing machines for their own sake
and what's happened for example in
mathematics is there's a big structure
of pure mathematics
that is quite independent of the
applications of mathematics to
particular fields
in computation that's been less clear i
mean part of it is theory of computation
but that's been
been pulled in very specific directions
to do with computational complexity
theory
development of of specific practical
algorithms and so on
not what is computation abstractly
and studying computations for its own
sake so i i think that um
the um that these this big area of sort
of study the computational universe for
its own sake
and understand principles about how it
works that's a huge
and and still rather open area um that
has been only a corner of it has been
sort of explored
with existing computation theory now i
realized that in defining these sort of
three directions for computer science
two of them are deeply connected to
things that i personally spent a lot of
time on
um i mean the the this whole
computational x how do you
how do you inject kind of computational
thinking into everything
and how do you provide the tools to do
that that's the thing that the whole
world language story
is about this whole area of sort of how
do you think about computation
at an abstract theoretical level that's
the whole kind of new kind of science
um and study the computational universe
area
the the practical programming area which
i view as being much more of a trade
school activity which doesn't
make it not useful it just makes it
different and not really
a a sort of intellectual science type
thing
it's more a do a trade and actually
build
stuff that uh that people need built
and so on and you know i think that
you're asking is computer science really
a science i think there are
the the the most core area of pure
computation
is is absolutely uh a science it is not
a well-developed science it's a science
i've tried
uh to to put some considerable effort
into defining and so on
um but it's still you know we're still
in the early years of that science
in terms of the sort of computational x
in a sense that's not computer science i
don't even conceivably computer science
that's the application of computation to
all these different areas just like
the application of mathematics in all
sorts of things whether it's physics or
economics or
or chemistry or whatever else you don't
usually talk about those as mathematics
not even applied mathematics
they're just mathematics as a method
methodology
um for uh for doing some other kind of
field
so i tend to think of that as as as the
story of computer science and it's it's
a very confusing thing for universities
right now
because lots of students come in and say
we want to study computer science
you know sometimes it's 70 percent of
the incoming students are saying
we want to study computer science what
do they actually want to study
they know computation is an important
paradigm they are trying to do
computational x
ultimately for some x they may or may
not yet know what the x
is but they're probably not going to be
in the trenches programmers and in fact
one of the things that is a as a
definite trend is
in the trenches programming you know
we're trying to automate that away
you know back when i started using
computers you know you programmed in
them in assembly language and people
even when i was building
our first sort of high level symbolic
system back in 1979
people were saying well of course to do
real computing you use assembly language
well nobody says that anymore um the uh
very almost nobody says that anymore
it's you know once dealing with things
that are a much more humanized level
and the the low-level programming
languages have
have are still not at that humanized
level and and the whole idea of our sort
of computational language and
language and so on is to make a bridge
to this sort of
human level of of thinking about
computation
um and bridge that to what computers are
actually doing
and so i think that's been uh
a um so you know that's a that's a
somewhat different kind of thing
that isn't there's there's a lot to
understand about
sort of the computational method and uh
i'm hoping i'll have a chance to write
more about these kinds of things because
i think
there's there's really a big story of
teaching people the computational method
which is not the same as teaching
computer science and
the computational method there is some
basic science to do around it although
it mostly
ends up in this sort of pure computation
area
and again very separate from the sort of
trade school aspect of
of just write code
let's see we should probably wrap up um
in just a moment here uh
there's a question from aaron here um
well let me not take that this time it's
a question about uh we we made in
in um i think it was like 2011 we made
this
big poster that's really nice you can
you can find a web version of it and
you can even i think still get the
physical poster it's a history
of um the uh development of systematic
data
and computable knowledge it's kind of
how did the world become
systematic in terms of data how did one
go from
just saying uh you know this
defining units of measure for weights
and things like this defining uh you
know how
how many hours are there in a day how do
you label chemicals
how do you do all these kinds of things
systematically um
and uh we kind of collected this sort of
long history of how that developed
it's pretty interesting i think the the
two winners of sort of
most systematic data collected in in
history but probably the babylonians and
the us government
um they're the two biggest collectors of
data and you can kind of see
the rise and fall of empires um as um
as you look at uh sort of the history of
systematic data
because you know it was it was uh the
the
the great you know empires or the or the
top
countries or whatever it is tend to be
the ones that were defining the
standards
that were in a particular period in
history that were ending up getting used
but the question is what what new things
um
are there that we can add to that and we
have
actually i think there's going to be a
revised version of it at some point
where we have a
a number of additions that um um
that we're going to make um
there was an interesting challenge i i
am
uh somebody said
um um
yeah this is this is perhaps an
interesting um interesting thing to talk
about somebody said
oh you know how come they're not we had
certain certain uh sort of innovators
marked out on this on this history of
systematic data
how come there aren't more women on this
timeline
and you know my
so i i sort of took that as a challenge
to um
uh to kind of um um
uh figure out you know
what was missing there and um
the um uh i think
um uh and it was um
it was interesting to uh to try and
you know my my goal
was to say were there pieces of history
that were missing
that shouldn't have been missing not
pieces of history that had to be made up
the pieces of history that were missing
perhaps not for very good reasons
as in for for whatever whatever
process of um uh of uh of the flow of
history
uh some contribution made by some some
woman wasn't
wasn't recognized in its time for some
for some reason because that woman
wasn't a member of some society or this
that or the other
um uh and and it sort of should have
been and when we look back on the
history we can see it was important and
and it was interesting because i did
find a number of examples i'll mention
um uh two
that um immediately come to mind um
although i'm not sure i'm going to be
able to give all the details
uh one was a custom called maria kunitz
and this was from
the 1600s i think um
and she was a person who
was involved in the systematization of
astronomy
and um in making astronomical tables and
so on
and um a uh i'm not going to be able to
give this history very well
um but that was that was a
um let's see i think was connected to um
maybe uh well supposedly called reggio
montanus
who is a person who was the person who
sort of systematized
trigonometry and then was responsible
for
a bunch of tables that predated people
like kepler
maria kunitz was in the middle of that
whole thing and i'm trying to remember
exactly
what the uh what the what the what the
um
uh what the details of that were and i
don't remember offhand
i'll mention one other example a person
in much more recent times
named karen spark jones who was a person
in cambridge
england um and who was really a key
person
in the development of text retrieval and
what became search engines
and um uh in inventing sort of
the idea of doing sort of computation
with text
and that had been an idea that hadn't
really
yes there were um there was sort of the
some people knew about you know storing
text in computers there'd been some
thoughts about
about things like language translation
in the early 60s and so on
but from what i can tell karen spark
jones was sort of a key person
in in making text retrieval
a um uh um
a kind of a a scientific area um
and uh i'm not sure if she invented um
uh tf idf um i think perhaps she did
term frequency inverse document
frequency which is a standard method
for figuring out kind of what's worth
indexing in a document that you have
what's a significant word and document
that you have and so on
um and
anyway that was that was a person who um
uh pulled beyond the next edition of our
of our timeline of systematic data and
um i i'm not quite sure why
uh you know i don't think this is
it's a i think what what happens there
is that this is a field you know the
science of text retrieval
just was a funny kind of field and it's
sort of a little bit
into library science is it computer
science but it wasn't really computer
science it was a little bit more like
library science but it wasn't really
library science
it's a it's a great sort of innovative
field area
but it isn't a um uh but it isn't
something where
um the uh that has sort of been in the
mainstream of oh yes it's famous because
it was this step in the development of
field
x which we all know about now of course
that particular field has become very
important
but even now i'm not sure what you would
call it you know what is the development
of the mechanics of a search engine it's
not really computer science it's a lot
of
stuff about details of language and
documents and what exists on the web and
things like this
it's again it's it's a funny area and i
think that's some
uh that's kind of a a reason why that
was not as
visible in history as it might have been
but um that was just one of the things
that
comes to mind in terms of things that um
i was curious about with that timeline
actually i think there were
another one or two examples but it was
some uh
uh interesting interesting process of of
trying to figure out um when there is
sort of um
history that got forgotten and another
big one not um
uh you know there are places where
there's a piece of history that really
was quite important
but it somehow got it never
it never engaged with some area that
was a big enough brand in a sense that
it got recognized oh that's an important
piece of history
i mean another one that i studied a
bunch towards the end of last year was
combinators
invented in 1920 by this chat moses sean
finkel
um which have been sort of footnotes to
history but they've actually been
footnotes on top of which a lot of
history has been built
but they haven't really been as much
recognized as a significant moment
in the history of thinking about
computation as i think they probably
should have been
and of course it's always very difficult
with these pieces of history
because there's kind of what you know
now
and what people knew then and there's
how do you interpret what people knew
then in terms of what you know
now and some of these things it's like
well now of course we understand all
about universal computation
and so we can see that so-and-so was
really talking about
universal computation but what they
actually said was something completely
incomprehensible
and you know it and i don't and the
question is what did it take
for one to really say yes they formed
the thought
that that particular of that particular
thing versus just they were flailing
around
and they happened to mention these words
that sound a bit like these words that
we have today
um and i know even in some of the things
i've done in my own
in my own life you know they're things
where i i know
i didn't really have the idea um
at some time in the past i got the idea
later given that idea later
i could project back and say well i was
flailing around more or less in the
right pond
but i didn't actually get to um the um
uh the the you know i didn't really
engage i didn't wrap my arms around
the idea and i was still just flailing
around and it took
it took another decade or two or more um
to get to that real
idea and i think one sees that to some
extent in
in history and sometimes sometimes
people write about things in a very
clear way
sometimes it's very muddy you know i've
been being quite curious about leibniz
and and what did he figure out and what
did he really know and i think i more or
less have that nailed down as far as
computation is concerned
but like i was just working on why does
the universe exist and leibniz worked on
that as well
and you know nailing down what did he
really know and could one take
could one interpret something he said in
terms of something we now can understand
much more concretely
in terms of a bunch of elaborate
mathematics and science that's been
developed since
can we sort of back project and say well
he almost had it or he had the main idea
hard to do in many cases and um so you
know that that's often a challenge in
sort of understanding what some
historical precursor looked like but
sometimes it's it's really clear
and um uh and that's some and sometimes
it's clear but unknown sometimes it's
clear but but
and the most common reason i think is
because things lie between between
different fields
and it's just like nobody wrote a
history of x
you know they've written a history of
chemistry but they haven't written a
history of this thing that's
somehow between you know chemistry and
archaeology or something
all right well i think we should wrap up
there i have to go back to my
day job here and um we're just working
on the
the latest version of uh wolfram
language and
releasing that which hopefully will
happen soon and
uh my day job right now is uh
writing about what's new in that in that
version which is always quite fun
so i think we should wrap up here for
now
thanks for joining us and um uh
hope to see you another time